CONGRESS TO RELEASE THE MEMO.
WE DESERVE THE TRUTH AND WHILE
THEY'RE AT IT RELEASE ALL 50,000
TEXTS.
>>> JOINING US WITH REACTION FOX
NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST BOB GORKA.
LOOK, IT'S A LOT TO TAKE IN.
WE TAKE EVERY BIT OF NEW TEXT
MESSAGES AND PUT IT WITH THE OLD
TEXT MESSAGES AND OTHER
INFORMATION WE GLEANED OVER THE
YEAR.
ALL FACTS.
NOW WE HAVE A VERY CLEAR PICTURE
OF WHAT WENT ON.
>> YES, INCREASINGLY THE
EVIDENCE IS MOUNTING NOW THAT
STRZOK AND PAGE AND OTHERS AT
THE FBI WERE ENGAGED IN WHAT'S
CALLED A CORRUPT PURPOSE.
STATUTE.
HILLARY CLINTON AND CHANGED THE
LANGUAGE FROM CHARGING HER TO
EXONERATING HER AND THIRD, THEY
DID IT FOR POLITICAL REASONS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED HER TO BE
PRESIDENT.
THEY THOUGHT SHE WOULD BE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO ANGER OR
LYNCH, THEY ALL KNEW AHEAD OF
TIME.
DON'T WRITE AN EXONERATION
BEFORE AN INVESTIGATION.
DID THEY OBSTRUCT JUSTICE?
>> IF THEY DID IT FOR A
POLITICAL REASON AND --
>> Sean: FOR ANY REASON?
>> THANK GOODNESS FOR ELECTRONIC
TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE THIS IS THE
SMOKING GUN EVIDENCE OF THEIR
MOTIVATIONS AND MOTIVATIONS IS
HOW YOU PROVE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> Sean: SEBASTIAN GORKA, YOU
WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE DURING A
LOT OF THE TIME.
I'M SURE IT TOOK TIME AND
ATTENTION FROM GOVERNING THE
PEOPLE BUT THE PRESIDENT STILL
HAD A GREAT YEAR.
WHEN YOU SEE THE LEVEL THE USE
OF FISA COURTS AND WEAPONRY, TO
ME IT'S CHILLING AS SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES IN EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW AND THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION.
>> IT IS TRULY CHILLING AS THE
CHILD OF PARENTS WHO ESCAPED
COMMUNISM, I NEVER THOUGHT I'D
SEE THE DAY WHERE THE VAUNTED
FBI, PEOPLE INSIDE THE AGENCY,
SENIOR MANAGEMENT INDIVIDUALS
WE WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE -- I
WAS SECURE THERE WERE NO ISSUES.
THE PRESIDENT TOLD ME THEY WILL
FIND NOTHING BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION.
WE'VE BEEN ACCUSED OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, WORK THE
RUSSIANS AND WE NOW KNOW INSIDE
OBAMA'S FBI THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY TO CONVERT THE COURSE
OF JUSTICE.
YOU MISHANDLE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION THAT'S A FELONY
AND --
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
MEDIA.
YOU'RE RIGHT ON EVERY POINT AND
SO IS GREGG.
WHAT ABOUT THE MEDIA, THEY'LL GO
WITH AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE ABOUT A
STORY THAT NEVER CAME TO
FRUITION WITH DONALD TRUMP.
HE'S ASKING IF THERE'S
CONFLICTS.
HE SAYS NO AND THEY MAKE THAT
BIG NEWS.
WITH ALL THE EVIDENCE --
>> LET'S PUT THIS IN CONTEXT.
YOU AND YOUR TEAM HAVE BEEN
DOING THE HEAVY LIFTING EVERY
A COURT OF LAW TO PROSECUTE
THESE PEOPLE AND WHAT ARE THEY
DOING?
A WEEK AGO THEY'RE ASKING THE
VICE ADMIRAL THE PRESIDENT'S
SURGEON, WHETHER HE'S STILL
DRINKING DIET COKE EVERY DAY.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST SCANDAL IN
COMPLICIT.
FIRED, HOW'S THAT A STORY.
>> IT'S A LEGITIMATE CONCERN OF
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: YES.
THE JOURNALISTS HAVE BEEN
THEY'VE NEVER READ THE LAW AND
IT REQUIRES A CORRUPT ACT BY THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> HE WAS ENGAGING IN A
LEGITIMATE ACT ACCORDING TO THEM
TRYING TO REMOVE MUELLER BECAUSE
OF HIS MYRIAD OF CONFLICTS OF
INTERESTS AND REPLACING HIM WITH
SOMEBODY WHO WOULD BE
LEGITIMATE, OBJECTIVE, FAIR AND
JUSTICE AND THESE IDIOT
JOURNALISTS -- I'VE WATCHED THEM
ALL DAY LONG --
>> THEY'RE NOT.
IT TAKES A NANOSECOND TO LOOK IT